タイトルは、「年内さいごのセミナーは残席九名　資産デザイン研究所メール　第七百四号　二千二十六年十月二日発行（パート1/2）」です。
まずはご挨拶からです。
こんにちは。
資産デザイン研究所メール第七百四号、二千二十六年十月二日、金曜日の配信です。
この資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家のみなさまにお届けする、ウィークリーのメールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとした実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」について、その具体的な方法をできるだけ客観的な視点でご紹介しています。
資産デザイン研究所と内藤忍の公式ブログなどもあわせてご活用ください。
ちなみに、内藤忍および株式会社資産デザイン研究所では、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行っていますが、金融商品の勧誘や推奨など、いわゆる投資助言業務は一切行っていません。
続いて、イベント・セミナーのお知らせです。
現在、年内さいごの開催になるかもしれない、「金利上昇下での不動産投資戦略セミナー」が十一月二日に予定されています。
このセミナーは、十二年続いている毎回好評の定番イベントなんです。
十一月も、追加で開催することが決まりました。
定員は十名限定で、東京ミッドタウン六本木で行います。
今回は「金利上昇下での不動産投資」について、最新の情報をご提供します。
いまの環境下で失敗しない物件の選び方や、お金の借り方についてもわかる内容です。
不動産投資が未経験の方や、初心者の方にもおすすめしています。
詳しい内容やお申し込みについては、リンクからご確認いただけます。
また、将来のお金について不安をお持ちの方に向けたセミナーと説明会もご案内しています。
内藤忍が主宰し、開講から十二年目を迎える「資産設計実践会」では、インナーサークル情報を活用して、個人投資家のお金の心配を解消するためのさまざまなコンテンツを提供しています。
金融資産だけでなく、国内外の不動産、さらには不動産以外の実物資産、暗号資産や節税戦略まで、幅広くカバーしています。
二百名近いメンバーが集まる投資家コミュニティに興味のある方は、まずはこのセミナーと説明会にご参加いただくことをおすすめしています。
詳しい内容やセミナー・説明会の参加申し込みについては、リンクからご覧ください。
ここからは、今回のメインコンテンツのご案内です。
今回の内容は、
一つめが、「資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ」です。
二つめが、「本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ」
三つめが、「読者の質問コーナー」
四つめが、「内藤忍の白米ダイエット日記」
五つめが、「資産運用日記」
六つめが、「内藤忍のつぶやき」
となっています。
続けて、公式ブログ「Shinoby`s World」のコラムタイトル一覧もご紹介します。
こちらは毎日更新している内藤忍の公式ブログの、前回のメールマガジン配信以降のコラム一覧です。
全文は公式ブログからお読みいただけます。
九月二十六日は、「ワイン会は『何を飲むか』よりも『誰と飲むか』」
九月二十七日は、「高級リゾートホテル会員権にあまり惹かれない訳」
九月二十八日には、「参加費七十六万円のワイン会に参加しようと思う訳」
九月二十九日、「秋の長雨は憂鬱だけど、松茸愛好家には朗報となる」
九月三十日は、「行列ができる人気店を効率よく利用する方法」
十月一日は、「奈良は観光地としてもっと人気化できる」
そして十月二日、「旅行に行くときに絶対に忘れてはいけないもの」となっています。
あわせて、内藤忍のメディア出演や出版情報もご案内します。
毎月更新されるマネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」では、最新のコラムタイトルが
「これから住むべき場所はどう決める？
」
となっています。
連載一覧も、リンクからご覧いただけます。
それでは、ここからは各コーナーの内容です。
まずは「資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ」についてです。
動けない為替マーケット
最近の為替マーケットは、円高にも円安にも大きく動きにくい、膠着状態となっています。
ドル円は、一ドル百五十八円を挟んだあたりの水準で小さな動きにとどまっています。
従来から円安への懸念を示していたアメリカのベッセント財務長官だけでなく、日本の財務官や閣僚からも、円安修正やリフレ政策を否定するような発言が出ました。
さらに高市首相自らが「円の過小評価は問題」と発言したことで、円安の動きにも歯止めがかかりました。
ただし、ファンダメンタルズを考えると、円安への圧力が依然として続いており、いまは二つの力が拮抗している状態です。
今後の為替マーケットの焦点となってくるのは、日米の景気動向と利上げのタイミングになるでしょう。
国内の債券市場では、日銀の利上げが前倒しになるとの意識が強まっており、短期の二年債の金利が二パーセント近くまで上昇してきました。
来春までにあと二、三回の利上げがあるのではと予想されていて、金利引き上げのペースが加速すると見込まれています。
アメリカでは、景気についてはさまざまな数字が発表され、強弱入り乱れている状況です。
そのため、利上げの確率も、経済データが発表されるたびに上下して、不透明な状態が続いています。
日米政府の要人から想定外の発言がなければ、しばらくは一方向に動きにくいマーケットが続きそうです。
ここからは、「本気でやる資産運用〜セミナー・イベントのご案内」です。
あらためて
現在受付中のセミナーは、年内さいごの開催になるかもしれない「金利上昇下での不動産投資戦略セミナー」（十一月二日）です。
また、「将来のお金の不安を解消したい方のための資産設計実践会セミナー＆説明会」についてもご案内しています。
続いて、「読者の質問コーナー」です。
読者の方からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリお答えします。
質問です。
「東京のファミリー向けの湾岸たわまんを購入しましたが、価格下落が続いていて、これからさらに下がりそうです。
売却してしまった方が良いでしょうか？
」
回答します。
ご質問、ありがとうございます。
確かに東京湾岸エリアのたわまんは、現在値下がりが続いており、こんごも価格調整が続く可能性が低くありません。
キャピタルゲインを狙った、いわゆる投資目的での購入の場合、これからの金利上昇によって、単に価格が下落するだけでなく、ローン返済の負担が大きくなることも考えられます。
仮に損失が出たとしても、早めに対応することで、マイナスが大きく拡大するのを防ぐことができます。
いっぽうで、実需、つまり住む目的で購入して住宅ローンの支払いをしている場合であれば、現在の住環境に満足しているなら、長期の居住を前提にして売却せずにそのまま住み続けても良いと考えます。
東京湾岸エリアは、こんごも再開発や交通インフラの整備、子育て環境の充実など、実需の強さは維持できるでしょう。
ですので、仮に短期的な価格調整があったとしても、実際の生活への影響はありませんし、再び資産価格が底打ちすることも充分考えられます。
また、住宅ローンを着実に返済していけば、借入元本が減少するため、たとえ価格が横ばいまたは少し下がるくらいだったとしても、実質的には含み資産が形成されていくことになります。
マイホームを売却したとしても、賃貸物件の家賃も値上がりしている状況ですので、焦ってマイホームを手放すメリットはそこまで大きくありません。
どちらのケースでも、まずは将来のローン返済や現状のマーケット価格など、客観的なすうじを把握してから最終的な判断をするのが良いでしょう。
このコーナーでは、読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所の代表取締役である内藤忍が、メールマガジン上で回答しています。
資産デザイン研究所からでした。
続いて、「内藤忍の白米ダイエット日記」のコーナーです。
今回は、「へたな高級店より美味しい北海道の立ち食い寿司チェーン」についてお話しします。
錦糸町に出かけたタイミングで、久しぶりに北海道発祥の有名な立ち食い寿司チェーンに入ってみました。
十三時を過ぎていましたが、祝日だったこともあってお店の前には行列ができており、入店まで少しだけ時間がかかりました。
このお店のスタイルはカウンターでの立ち食いで、食べたいネタを紙に書いて職人さんに直接手渡しするというシステムです。
まずはやっぱり、北海道のニシンからいただきました。
東京の寿司店ではあまり見かけないネタです。
光りものの鯖とはまた違った香りと舌触りを楽しむことができました。
筋子も、外せないネタですね。
シャリの上に、たっぷりと筋子が覆いかぶさるくらい乗っています。
ねっとりとした食感とほどよい塩気が、お酒を進めてくれます。
カニの外子の軍艦巻きは、カニの小さな卵が口の中でプチプチと弾けて、まさに珍味といった感じ。
トビコのような食感で楽しませてくれました。
そして、名物の帆立の二階建てもやっぱり外せません。
肉厚な帆立の新鮮な切り身が、二段に重なっているボリューム満点の握りです。
一口ではとても食べきれないので、重なった帆立を一枚ずつ味わっていきました。
ちなみに、このチェーンの新橋駅にある店舗が、厨房の工事のため三ヶ月以上も閉店になっていて、久しぶりの利用となりました。
このお店は立ち食いスタイルの大衆的なお店なので、シャリの品質や握り具合といった細かい点は、高級店にはやっぱり敵いません。
でも、ネタの新鮮さではまったく引けを取らず、ものによっては高級寿司店よりも美味しいのでは？
と思うくらいのクオリティです。
予約なしで、ふと思いついたときにサクッとお寿司が食べられるお店としてはピカイチだと思いました。
早く近所にある新橋店がまた復活してほしいものです。
今回ご紹介したのは、「立食い寿司　根室花まる錦糸町テルミナ店」、東京都墨田区江東橋三−十四−五、錦糸町テルミナ一階にあります。
電話番号は、ゼロハチゼロの六ゼロ八三の八四八三です。
ここから「資産運用日記」です。
テーマは「不動産投資は地方が熱くなる」についてです。
東京都心部の区分ワンルームにおける賃貸利回りが低下し、ローンの金利が上がっていることでイールドギャップが縮小しています。
その影響もあって、別の不動産投資対象を探そうという方が増えてきました。
そんな中で、代替の候補として注目を集めているのが、地方での宿泊事業なんです。
この先は、次回パートツーで続きをご紹介します。
まず、宿泊物件を取得して、日本人やインバウンド観光客を対象に旅館業として貸し出す仕組みについてのお話です。
すでにニセコなどでは、外国人がたくさん集まっていて、その影響で物件価格が上がっています。
また、ニセコに続いて、長野などのスキーリゾートエリアでも投資資金が流れ込んでいて、地価が上がっている場所もあります。
でも、それ以外にも、探してみれば、まだまだ開拓されていない地方の物件はたくさん残っています。
例えば、オーシャンビューや、雄大な山の景色を眺めることができる場所、あるいは、かけながしの温泉が楽しめるエリアなど、本当にさまざまな観光資源が眠っている場所が、日本各地に存在するんです。
自治体が観光事業に積極的な地域であれば、宿泊事業を始めるハードルもかなり低くすることができます。
リスク自体は高くなりますが、これから地方不動産への投資はどんどん熱くなっていきそうですね。
ここからは、内藤忍のつぶやきです。
京都と奈良に行ってきました。
こんしゅうは、いつものパターンで、京都と奈良に出かけてきたんです。
ホテルも前回と全く同じところを利用し、予約して行ったお店も、ほぼ同じでした。
旅行先でやっぱり気になるのは天気ですよね。
今回は雨が多くて、少し憂うつだったんですが、後半にはなんとか天気も回復して、気持ちよく旅先を歩き回ることができました。
観光はほとんどせず、ひたすら飲んで食べるばかり。
帰ってから体重がどうなっているかは、考えないことにしています（笑）。
みなさんは週末、いかがお過ごしでしょうか？
私は日曜日に、不動産会社が主催するセミナーで、投資家の方たちにお話をさせていただきます。
秋はセミナーシーズンということで、しばらくはセミナーや講演会で忙しい日々が続きそうです。
みなさんも、ぜひ素敵なしゅうまつをお過ごしください。
資産デザイン研究所メールの解除や変更については、こちらから手続きをお願いします。
また、ご意見やご感想もお待ちしています。
最後に、免責事項についてです。
内藤忍資産デザイン研究所メール、いわゆる本メールは、資産デザイン研究所、つまり当社が発行しているメルマガです。
本メールの著作権は当社に帰属していますので、もし複製や再配信などを行う場合は、当社までご一報いただけますようお願いいたします。
掲載された内容は、執筆時点での筆者の見解や予測であり、情報の正確性や完全性を保証するものではありません。
また、こんご予告なく内容が変更されることもありますし、過去の実績も将来の結果を保証するものではありません。
本メールは、あくまで情報提供のみを目的にしているもので、実際に投資を行う際の最終的な判断は、お客さまご自身の判断と責任でお願いします。
以上、資産デザイン研究所メールの内容をお伝えしました。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。